Carissa went up to me James said what up
to me and they both told me like just
keep going uh after that one I was kind
of like all right yeah like I'm cool on
all right now I'm over the fan
all right so Tyrese it is good to see
you as always
um and although you are a dear friend of
mine we have a long-standing feud about
the draft that happened
on Old Man in the 30. so shout out to JJ
and Tommy first of all
secondly I think that we need to settle
this once and for all so the draft was
moments in history in American history I
feel like you're adding that on I think
that's another point of contention for
us okay okay but you say American
history will say it was moments in
American history that we wish Twitter
existed yes
I feel like I ran away with this draft I
think I was the clear winner
why do you disagree you chose the birth
of Jesus if I'm correct and
I don't know what if that's American
history and two who's tweeting about it
that's the point because it's like oh
you're like oh my gosh the birth of
Jesus Christ how did this happen
yeah but I wanted pics I want to like
picks that made sense like the OJ Chase
like we had that that makes that's
logical yeah but
the birth of Jesus who's who's tweeting
about it one and that's not American
history we said don't do anything crazy
did somebody pick the big bang that is
also a great pick you picked that
another great pick I just want to also
be clear though as we talk about this
the audience said I won did they yes or
no they did I cannot lie but I was I was
thinking like 1990s 80s moments like
like positive moments and there was just
some wild card picks you picked the
birth of Jesus and the Big Bang somebody
picked some other crazy stuff I went
with some realistic things and I
probably finished last in the draft so
yeah sorry so you have been on Twitter
long enough to know that is not the
place or positivity that's a fact
unfortunately so I was playing to the
Twitter audience yeah what are some
things that this app would just go back
and forth about forever
and that's why I made my picks yeah
that's fair yeah I totally get it but so
we got to get to another Feud and that
is what did you do to Wally zerbiak I I
have no clue
um I have my phone's been blowing up
about it the past couple days just
people sending me it uh you know I I
think everybody's entitled to their own
basketball opinion uh but yeah to be
honest I'm a basketball historian I feel
like I know a lot about the game
I know the name Wally zerbiak I couldn't
tell you where he played I couldn't tell
you what he did as a basketball player
um no disrespect to these people who
come before me but uh I don't know he
had a lot to say about me I was really
like questioning like first who is this
and uh why is he talking about me like
this but it happens yeah so to set the
stage he did he called you what a
wannabe All-Star yeah yeah but I feel
like there was some more color in there
though it was it was definitely pretty
poignant yeah he made the point pretty
emphatically a couple times and I don't
know if I ever came out and said like
I want to be an All-Star this year
please vote for me I didn't I didn't I
don't think I've done that so uh
uh yeah I don't know I think he was just
excited about a Knicks win
um and that got him going but uh you
know we played next game in a couple
weeks and uh you know I'm just gonna
continue to worry about what I have
going on in on our on our side of things
and uh you know he's just doing whatever
he can to get attention and uh that's
just that's just the media these days so
when you hear you know media members or
former players are now in the media
discussing your game are there times
where it hits differently than others if
you hear that does it make you feel away
about yourself or how do you kind of
compartmentalize what people are saying
about you yeah I think it's I don't know
I think I'm a human being so you have
your days where you try to let things
kind of just brush off and but you you
choose who you you know listen to for me
it's like uh you know people who really
know me people who I value their
opinions right like if Magic Johnson
comes out and says anything about me
positive or negative that's going to
mean something to me because I've
watched him you know my whole my whole
life like from old film and stuff like
LeBron we played the Lakers the other
day he had something to say about me uh
granted it was positive but that meant a
lot to me because I grew up watching him
um but there's some people who like uh
shout out to my guy mgrad left hand
layup challenge like am I really like
some a lot of people on Twitter or do I
care what you if they can't make a
left-hand layup why does it why does
that matter to me so like that's the
barometer there's so many times I want
to reply to people and be like yo send
me a video of you making a left-hand
layup full speed uh and then maybe I'll
think about it but uh yeah I think
that's comes with kind of the notoriety
of being an NBA player everybody has
their opinions on you and you got to
choose who you listen to and
I mean so it came from you missing the
go-ahead jumper to potentially win the
game for your team against the Knicks I
didn't necessarily understand the
correlation between missing that shot
and being an All-Star
yeah like I said he's I think it's just
the thing for clicks right yeah it's
every major media outlet has said
something about it to this point I've
been tagged in it a million times on
social media so it's just whatever to
get people talking
um you know the unfortunate part of some
former NBA players they just want to
hear their name you know be said again
and so that just that comes with it but
um yeah I mean he's entitled to his own
opinion as a basketball player I just
hope when I'm you know done playing that
that's not me out I don't see no point
to you know hate on the people coming
after me or the ones before me to be
honest but uh it happens well you are
taking it like a like a true Pro but on
that subject I mean All-Star that has to
be something that you do have your site
set on what is that a goal for you
coming into this year and where do you
feel like you're lining up at this
moment uh for me you know this is like
obviously my first opportunity to be a
lead guard there's been a lot of
expectations and people who wanted to
see what I would bring this year being a
you know the full-time point guard here
and all the hype and love I get in
Indiana so you know I was really excited
to come into the air and just perform
the way that I wanted to you know I
worked really really hard this summer to
have a successful year and I didn't know
what that was because I had never seen
it and I think as an NBA player for me
it's like how can I be the best version
of Tyrese Halliburton not like how can I
you know be better than this guy better
than that guy it's just like what is the
best version of me and I don't know that
and I still think we're a few years from
being able to know exactly what that is
but it's exciting for me and and it all
comes with Team success I mean we're out
performing expectations and that's
making me look better and making a lot
of other guys look better because we're
doing better as a team so that's the
biggest thing but even my dad this
morning uh he was at my house when I was
packing getting ready to go and he was
like yo can you believe that guy said
that about you about the All-Star like
All-Star like who would have thought
that you'd all start at this point like
that's my dad he's my biggest fan so
like for him to say that it's still like
wow you know it's crazy that we're here
but
um you know as long as the the team's
doing the right things everything else
will follow no I love that you know one
thing that I have learned about really
just like life and goal setting in
general I've talked about about this
before is sometimes when we set these
expectations for ourselves or our team
we unknowingly are limiting what the
outcome could be like I'm sure you got
to the Pacers and you had an idea of
like okay these are my expectations this
is what I can do but as time kept going
on and you realized how good this team
was those expectations continue to shift
and go up and go forward so what did you
think the team could do when you first
arrived and so what do you think they
can do now how did that change so when I
first arrived it's a funny story I tell
people this all the time
um I got traded the Pacers played the
Hawks that day in Atlanta but they had
just traded three guys everybody was
hurt so they barely squeaked out enough
guys to even play the game so I turned
the game on with my girl and were
watching it she doesn't know a ton about
NBA basketball but she was looking at me
the whole time like
you're going to this like are you not
watching this like are you okay yeah I
was like trying to it's okay like we'll
be fine uh so like last year was just
like I mean obviously they kind of had
the same record that I had with the
Kings before I got there and uh it was
obvious that we weren't gonna make the
playoffs I don't I think last year we
lost the last 10 or whatever the case
may be and so it's kind of just about
getting familiar with guys kind of
understanding what uh how I can be
better like the adjustment for me to be
like from like second third on the
scouting reports and moving to the first
guy it really you know showed for me
last year and so coming into this year
obviously there's a lot of talk about
miles can get traded but he could get
traded
um you know nobody's really safe on our
roster coming into the air so
um you know I was just thinking well the
roster that we do have I think there's
like a chance there I think we have a
chance to do something uh to get back to
the playoffs I think we got I think it's
hard with you know if you have me Ben
miles and Buddy and some other guys it's
hard for that team you know to struggle
so I was looking at it like I think
think there's a chance there so just
coming in the year it was like let's
just uh prove people wrong like I think
we were picked 15th in the east by every
major Sports Outlet there is uh probably
30th in the NBA uh you know a lot of
people saying we were in the wemby
sweepstakes and stuff like that and so
like for me it was like and I don't want
to do that like yeah like let's win
let's do what we can and like try to
prove people wrong so it's exciting no
yeah it's been so fun to watch and what
game or moment did it really hit you
like yeah I'm the first guy on The
Scouting Report now oh yeah that's
interesting I don't know if I can point
out anything in specific uh I think last
year was kind of just a Ebbs and flows
type of time like when I first got there
I think I had like maybe like 2010 in
the first game and then it was like all
right have a good game here and then
like we played OKC and like I was
expected to take the game winner and I
was like I've never been in this
situation before since like college you
know
um so it's like okay now I see the
expectations not only from you know how
other people are guarding me but from
our us from an organizational standpoint
and everybody looking at me like
make her miss it we're letting you like
you're gonna shoot it and so I think
that's a crazy transition period for me
because everybody when you come to the
NBA everybody was a superstar in high
school everybody was a superstar in
college like most everybody was stars in
college yeah when you get to NBA you're
just trying to buy into a role and for
me when I got to SAC I'm just like
trying to buy into how I can like how
can I play and how can I like eventually
start and then how can I coincide with
the Aaron and how can we do something
successful versus coming to Indiana and
it was kind of like starting from
scratch almost because it was I guess a
soft rebuild it was a kind of a quick
thing but
um just kind of being looked at as the
guy in multiple facets is different yeah
I know there is obviously a lot of a lot
of talk and attention around that trade
and you ending up you know with the
Pacers I know it was initially really
difficult for you but now do you feel
like this is almost serendipitous like
you were supposed to be here in this
moment and you're doing the things that
you're supposed to be doing yeah for
sure for sure and I think obviously at
an immature thing immature view on
things when happened
and let's just call it it's like I was
hurt like I was really frustrated with
everybody and everything and I know like
eventually this sound bite is going to
come out and people are going to be like
he doesn't shut up about the trade right
I asked the question guys yeah yeah so
like and obviously I was mad but when I
got to India it was like man why would I
question God's plan for me and um just
understanding that I'm I'm here for a
reason this is another organization who
values me
um you know another organization who has
a lot of faith in me as a basketball
player and a person and that means a lot
and so instead of taking my energy and
putting it towards something negative
and just being mad all the time and you
know talking about negative things it's
like how can I put this into something
successful and turn it into something
positive
um you know for for me myself but us as
an organization as well
and I'm talking generally here not
specifically about the you know the ins
and outs of the trade but you said
something that is simple but really
profound because a lot of people don't
just say when their feelings have been
hurt and I think that at the core of
almost everything it's hurt feelings
whenever you're like sad or upset you
feel like somebody has hurt you in some
way how do you get over hurt feelings
and not let them impact how you view
yourself
yeah
yeah that's a tough question I think
it's
it's different for everybody their
processed behind it for me it's like a
lot of self-reflection to be honest
um like kind of taking a step back and
understanding like uh like where am I
where my feet are right now where do I
want to go you know things like that
like I did exercise this summer I did a
little uh camp with PGC great great
great people and we were writing down
like our regrets in life our resentments
in life like I was like resentments I
mean resentments I was like hold on
Sacramento Kings and then I was like
that is so dumb that I'm like holding on
to that and still angry about that
um so like it honestly took until like
mid late summer for me to get over it uh
understanding that I had a great
opportunity in front of me and things
are going to happen but still just I'm
still just mad to be honest and
um you know social media people calling
me out all the time like that's
frustrating as well uh but it was like
you know like some like you said like
I'm getting asked these questions and
I'm answering them and I'm thinking like
I'm being real and authentic and I'm
telling the truth and then people are
just like all right shut up you know and
so then I'm like all right like there's
a question in your mind like are they
right like should I stop talking about
it and I think the great part of where
we are today is that us as athletes were
allowed to share our emotions and share
how we feel and not be looked at crazy
and I think that's important uh we're in
a great great space today and obviously
there's room for us to grow as a
culture as a world
um but yeah just for me it's a lot of
self-reflection just looking at it like
how can I be better and how can I get
over this to turn that negative energy
into something positive did writing your
regrets and resentments help you get rid
of them I think so I think so and it was
crazy because it was it was an exercise
where people obviously were writing
about you know there's a coach that
might have wronged them or something you
know what I mean something like that
maybe it was a girl maybe it was you
know what I mean what was it uh and for
me it was like almost like a whole
organizational a whole organization you
know and and I don't have any feelings
about it anymore like it's done and over
I'm excited to be here we went to SAC I
was like all right this game might mean
a little more for me we got popped like
like it happened you know and so like uh
you just gotta kind of move on and yeah
um you know think things will you know
work out for the best you know when you
talk about what athletes talk about in
the media it's almost like this lose
lose because because so I'm a person who
wants athletes to be really authentic
and real and talk about what's on their
mind and you would think that's what
most people want but then they'll say
something you're like well I didn't want
you to say that I didn't want you to be
that real how have you learned to
navigate kind of that balance and not
about talking about that but just in
general because you're a person who is
always themselves you step in as you and
that's what you give to others but I can
also see why sometimes you'd feel like
you almost can't be yourself yeah yeah
you know I I think
for me it's kind of understanding like
what what are people going to take from
this and
is this like a positive or negative am I
helping anybody out there by sharing my
emotions and my feelings and letting
people feel like they can be open about
things uh but to be honest for me it's
just like how I was raised by my mom and
dad to just be who you are
um and be honest in your truth you know
be honest in who you are as a person and
sometimes there's times where I just
hold back from saying what I really want
to say because it's like
what is this going to be turned into
because that's what the me that's what
media is today is like how can we turn
this sound bite into something uh bigger
than it is and that happens all the time
and so it's just kind of understanding
when's the right time to talk about
things when's the right time not to uh
how do I bite my tongue on certain
things and how do I speak out about
certain things and it's kind of on a
case-by-case basis like what's worth
your time and energy uh but I mean there
are some guys who are just
unapologetically them all the time and
uh for better or worse and uh but I
think every athlete has time so it's
like I'm just bite my tongue on this one
and move on because it's just not worth
your energy do you consider any part of
yourself a member of the media now that
you're a uh you're a little
correspondent yeah I know I I don't know
I I think a lot of people I get people
come up to me in the airport all the
time or where I am like yo JJ needs to
give you your own podcast and I'm like
no yeah like I don't want to talk about
basketball all the time you know yeah
um but I you know I think trayvon's
funny because he's got like the whole
like New Media thing hashtag New Media
whatever yeah uh but I don't I don't
think I'm necessarily a part of the New
Media but
maybe I am because I'm on there kind of
often you are on there and I do talk
basketball so yeah maybe I am but that
doesn't even sound right me saying that
so I'm gonna say no for now really no I
feel like it's at minimum it's a gray
area a gray area
but I think you're like okay dang I
don't want to just be the podcaster yeah
yeah you're like I don't want to just be
playing the game and then setting up my
mic
that's a fact yeah okay if you had a
podcast that you weren't talking about
basketball on what would the podcast
topic be okay yeah well I mean currently
I have a podcast with autograph right
now where we talk about crypto and stuff
like that
um but uh I don't know for me it's like
I just like to chill at the house chill
my dog and game so like it's like I like
being on Twitch like I like gaming and
just talking to fans and stuff like that
versus having a whole podcast like I
like going on JJ from time to time uh to
share basketball knowledge or you know I
love being it like last year during the
finals I was really big on what Wiggins
was doing like I was kind of pointing
that out early and now it makes me look
like a genius but I think I really was
just like liking what Wiggins was doing
and so like it makes me look better than
I am but
um sometimes it's like going on there
and just talking hoop because I mean at
the end of the day basketball is mostly
my life so yeah you know it's like
sharing knowledge for sure well you were
great on NBA Twitter live so I can I see
the full-fledged media potentially in
the future yeah in the future yeah when
you're not lacing them up and then get
in the water yeah about all those things
um you talked about your mama Ben and
how your parents have raised you to be
this person I know I've made you tell
the story before but it's my favorite
Story please tell everyone about your
mom's birthday and the gift or lack of
that you gave her on the court yes so my
mom up until College never missed a game
of My Life
um she missed a couple games in college
but not a ton so she always comes to my
NBA games she moved to Sacramento my
second year yeah my second year she
moved to Sacramento so now she's at
every game at home so for her birthday I
got her tickets to core side we're
playing the Sixers George nyang good
friend of mine she's like so excited she
has to watch me against George
um then this the Sixers come out for the
game and they're like yeah we're sitting
six dudes like we're not playing our
whole starting five and I'm like oh
I'm like all right I'm about to cook
tonight
Donuts zero points it's like over six uh
something like that no points uh
uh no points no points and I was just
sick when I got to the back uh but then
this year we played the 21st the day
before her birthday uh I wore the same
shoes I was like I'm gonna wear the same
shoes to like right my wrong hair not a
good game I love it inside of all the
games now so it's exciting okay but when
you came back to her when you had the
zero points did she like say anything
about it or was it just like okay we
know I didn't have a good game let's
leave it be there was no comment like
dang you had zero on my birthday but
it's more like uh like you know whole
you know I hope the seats were awesome
you know I love you she left the house
and I was sitting there kind of looking
at the ceiling like dang I really had
zero my mom's birthday crazy crazy no
I'm so like because I texted you the day
before your mama's birthday I'm like all
right we're gonna get them this year
career night for you so I'm glad it went
it went better this time around yes good
I love that story legit my favorite how
do you bounce back from a game like that
though
well I recently had a game against Miami
with one point yeah and
um that was tough because it's like
again I say like I don't want to talk
about basketball time but it is my life
and it does sometimes I always tell
people when they have bad games like yo
once you shower it's off you go home get
over it yeah it'll be better tomorrow
and for me it just stuck with me like I
couldn't sleep like just looking at the
ceiling like what just happened uh and
they had I mean Eric supposed to the
Miami Heat such a great team yeah they
defend at a high level bam is probably
the best switch big in the league
um I mean I feel like I was missing
shots and uh especially early I was just
missing some shots and then I got to the
point where like I was overthinking
about everything and I think us as NBA
players when there's a great shooter
struggling I think it's a mental thing
yes you know and so that's with anybody
like they're just taking that extra
thought and now shots aren't going and
they're thinking too much and that's
where I was to be honest I was
completely like I stayed at the gym for
like two hours after the game and shot
uh on the practice side and I was like
you know it's like one of those days
where it's like all right you're
shooting by yourself and you're making
them and you're like mad you're making
them and then you're missing them and
you're mad you're missing them yeah
what's going on with me and it just took
it took took over me a little bit and so
like it was like the great thing about
the mbas you play
in a day two days three days so like the
next day of practice I wasn't myself I
was pissed everybody can knew I was
pissed uh everybody all the coaches want
to talk to me about I'm like I don't
want to talk to you about it let's just
get to tomorrow yeah
um and then even to start that game
against Golden State I was struggling I
felt like nothing could go
um but it's just a mental thing more
than anything it's just like how can you
put your energy towards something else
and not and not like you know be stuck
on one point because I know I'm not a
one point player like yeah if I had two
three games in my whole NBA career at
one point or less so
um or less or less Zero's birthday uh
but it's just trying to get over it as
quick as possible and uh just
understanding that you know everybody
has good days bad days I'm I'm not gonna
sit here and tell you that's my last
game ever having zero field goals right
yeah that's probably gonna happen again
I hope I play this game a long time and
uh it's probably gonna happen again but
um you know it happens through the
course of a year and you just gotta move
on how has something like overthinking
impacted your life and your life as a
basketball player yeah uh I think it's
it's everything I think that's
everything I think I have a lot of
friends who overthink about things and
it's easy when it's not you yeah to be
like yo stop thinking about it you're
good get over it yeah uh but it's hard
when it's you and it's hard when it's
something that digests your life is
something that's like so important like
there's people who you know if it's like
overthinking about their job or a
marital problem or whatever the case may
be like it's hard not to because it's it
is it's a part of their everyday life
and it's a major part of it so
um yeah anytime I'm in a in a struggle
uh not having like the best like week of
games or whatever for me it's like take
a step back and like look at the grand
scheme of things like I took I was like
all right I shot 048 really how do you
evaluate a game on eight shots like how
do I how do I do that like I could have
made my next five or six and been six
for fourteen exactly and we would never
talk about it again like nobody would
ever say anything about it in a negative
way so uh like I didn't give myself a
chance to even have a decent game
because I started thinking too much and
that's kind of been the mental shift for
me going from
being a guy who's just a ball mover and
a role guy to like trying to make that
jump to be a you know All-Star in this
league jump to you know help change an
organization is like I kind of have to
get old like I'm almost a perfectionist
to a sense if that makes sense yeah and
so like my whole life I've shot a good
field goal percentage a good three-point
percentage like that's just been because
I'm like
they shot prying I'm going imma get off
it you know I mean I missed four in a
row I'm not shooting this one whereas
like I still go through that through the
course of a season because it's hard to
just change your mentality I think at
times
um but that's where I have to get to is
like I missed four in a row I might miss
this one I'm gonna make this one if I
miss it the next one going yeah and so
that's always thinking that exactly
thinking about the positive things so
yeah uh that's that's the biggest
struggle I'm at right now and just
trying to get over that in the best way
I can yeah you know it's funny because
whenever somebody you know says they're
perfectionist or talks about being a
perfectionist a lot of the time you
almost take it as a positive you're like
they want things to be perfect and be
right but being a perfectionist can hurt
you a lot of times too because then you
won't stop until it's exactly what you
think and a lot of the times when you're
just being loose and a lot of things to
happen that actually is the Perfection
yeah like make creating the Perfection
can be really really hard because then
you are going to think about how well
you're already not perfect because you
miss those other ones for sure but
instead of thinking about it as well
there's more time to be perfect and so
just like shifting how like how you view
it in that way
um I feel like what happens well if that
makes sense yeah for sure and it's like
coming into this year I would have never
said I'm a perfectionist I would have
never agreed with anybody about that
like I would have been like no I don't
see what you're talking about
um but Drew Hanlon my my trainer that I
started working shout out to Drew uh he
calls me after every game he'd be so mad
at me like I have a game I have a game
like 30
14 and like three steals no turnovers
he'll call me and just be pissed because
he's like you had 25 in the first half
and you Shot Two Shots in the second
half and I'll try to come up with an
excuse and he's like I'm not accepting
it you know what I mean yeah and uh it's
just like those games like he's like
I'll be more proud of you if you go
if you go one for you know one for 16
and have six points versus you going you
know 10 for 11 and having 28. like he's
like I'd rather it be the other way you
know because that just meant you know
you just kept shooting you you weren't
worried about that and so I'm seeing the
mental shift for you and uh he's the one
who's holding me accountable to that all
the time and uh you know it means a lot
to have him in my corner that's so great
I love you drew Hanlon he's great what
he works out with you with Jason Tatum
with embiid yeah I'm missing another
uh Brad yeah Tyler yeah yeah no he's
great he's a great shout out to Drew
um I was reading an interview that you
did with the ringer and you said
something that I thought was really
profound saying that Talent evaluation
is hard because you can't evaluate heart
elaborate on what you mean like that
what's heart to you yeah I mean I think
it's like your heart your mental right
like how you like Talent evaluators only
really see
what's on the floor right and for them
heart is does he play hard like does he
play hard what does that mean yeah you
know what I mean or like he just had a
bad game he had a better game the next
game that's heart like
what does that mean you know what I mean
and so it's like for me I think the way
I look at it I was a number 12 pick and
whatever reason that was and you know
don't know I mean I told people no I
think sometimes they want me whatever
the case may be right and then if you do
a redraft I'm probably drafted higher
right and so it's like people are always
like how did this team Miss on Tyrese
How did this team Miss on Desmond Bane
how did this team Miss on Tyrese Maxi
right like you can't evaluate how hard
guys work like that's tough because when
it comes to like we're coming out of
college right or coming out of high
school coming out of wherever these town
evaluators are going to ask people in
our life or people who have been around
us how hard does this person work
what do you think my college coach is
going to say about how hard I work he's
the hardest hardest worker of them all
right yeah and like that could be true
but but
probably a lot of times isn't true yeah
yeah and they could ask this person and
that person you know like how does he
react to a bad game oh he just like you
know he's really positive the next day
she can't wait to get to the next one
like no like that's not the truth yeah
and like so these Talent values aren't
always getting the truth from people and
that's just how it is and sometimes they
could go to people who they feel will
have an unbiased opinion and that does
happen from time to time but
um you can't evaluate how hard a person
is willing to work
um you know I think some guys peek at a
or like this is the player you are at 25
years old and they're just that player
for the rest of their career and I mean
that's that that happens all the time
but you know like what guy's willing to
go every off-season and you know put a
new part to their game and
um you know what would make a guy fall
in love with the game more to when he
was like 19 he didn't really want to
like he liked basketball but it's
whatever by the time he's 25 he's
thinking like man I probably want to
coach when I'm done you know that
happens all the time like you can't
evaluate that that's impossible to
evaluate so but like man Talent
evaluation is hard it is hard I don't
envy those people I don't at all because
you're making tough decisions that have
a future outlook that how do you really
know what the case may be you don't know
what could happen or you know what guy's
gonna Blossom what guy is not and so
um it's it's hard but uh so that's why I
don't that's why I don't really dwell on
like I was a 12th pick or you know like
for me it's like still a 12th pick like
I was a lottery pick like yeah these are
good problems have but I could I kind of
could pick up you don't necessarily love
that you are the 12th oh yeah not a big
fan not a big fan of of uh some of the
teams that have passed on me but I mean
like I understand it's hard and like
people always think it's like my friends
thought it was cool that like I could
name the 11 guys drafted before me but
I'm like
I'm not the guy who's like undrafted to
name all six years it's only 11. come on
it's not that big of a deal yeah where
did you think you were gonna go oh
um
okay so going to the night there was a
lot of options that I thought were
possible but I would say the number one
would be Detroit
I thought I was gonna go to Detroit for
sure really yeah I was I had a really
good workout with them good interview
thought everything went well
um I thought for sure I was going to
Detroit to be honest yeah and that was
Killian yeah kill you one seven yeah
okay yeah so that was so many wow and so
you were like this is gonna be my spot
you felt like through conversations
through feel it was going to be yeah I
thought I thought so I mean going into
the draft I I actually had a call to
Sacramento like a day or two before the
draft and they were like we're trying to
trade up to get you
because I get okay like you guys waited
till November tell me to talk to me
um but like they sent us a big box with
draft hats in them right and they were
sorted by division and so I went through
them and I put the team most likely in
the division to pick me in front of of
each slot right so I was like because I
was like you don't know who's gonna pick
you like yeah Mom if if this team picks
me you got to grab the hat like it's
gonna be in the front and so like the
Pacific Division the only team likely
was the Kings and so like everybody
would ask me that day like where do you
think you're gonna get drafted all my
friends I'd be like ah Sacramento
because they basically gave me a promise
at 12 if they were there and so I was
like a lot of times where people ask me
a question and I'll kind of set the bar
low because if it's higher I'll feel
better about it you know so I was like
oh I'll be the 12th I'm gonna go 12 to
the Kings but I didn't actually think
that I was gonna go 12 to the king oh
you were like I'm going to Detroit I was
like yeah I was like Chicago could pick
me at four Detroit could pick me at
seven New York could pick me at eight
Golden State might trade down all these
different start all these different you
know possibilities and exactly that'll
be inside wow so it could have been you
were piston initially yes yes it could
have been got it what an interesting
little tidbit yeah so like what was your
shock level when you weren't picked uh
nothing okay nothing nothing because it
was like I'm gonna go at some point yeah
yeah I was not a highly ranked kid
growing up and like so I was like I've
kind of felt like my whole life I've
been overlooked so I was like it's not a
new feeling for me to like be passed up
on or you know I mean it's not a new
feeling so yeah uh you know I just kind
of understand that there's so many
little things about the draft that like
you never really realize like I don't
think most fans know this stuff about
the hat like what things about the draft
surprised you when you were actually
there like oh this is how it works well
like I was in the covert draft too so
like yeah way different than everybody
else but like so you had to just be
ready to do it for on air on air yeah
because it was like you had to everybody
had to assign a person to hand in the
Hat and had like a meaning to it and for
me it was like my mom because I love my
mom yeah like she's gonna hand me the
hat but like you know wojin and Shams
have the the draft pick before right so
like I told everybody I'm like I'm not
gonna look
I was like but I had them both on
notifications so I was like there you go
and I'd look across the room my agent
Dave
like right like you know while it still
says like you know a minute left I
haven't made the pick yet he'd look at
me and be like
the whole time right I'm like oh okay
okay you know like and like on Jay
bills's Big Board I was four so like
after the first three picks it was like
Panda Tyrese Panda Tyrese Panda Tyrese
and I'm just sitting in my living room
like chilling hi guys like yeah I don't
know what's going on either yeah you
know so yeah there's a bunch of little
things but yeah the cover draft is a
very interesting time yeah would you say
you're a fan of the knowing before the
person is drafted or do you like taking
yourself out of it like besides this
went into new draft do you like that we
know the picks before they're announced
um
not really yeah I don't really like it
but the fact that it's there I have to
look yeah I got what was that
notification today so like don't we all
yeah so like I'm gonna know the pick and
like this year when it was bad like I
knew that if the Kings took Keegan at
four that we were that was a Keegan went
for Ivy went five yeah math and one six
yeah I knew that if
Keegan went four we were gonna get bent
at six and so when I saw the Wolves
notification it was like because I
wasn't able to watch the draft at the
time I was flying and I was like oh yeah
yeah I really like Ben I interviewed him
obviously after the Pacer drafted him
and he just has such a good energy and a
good confidence about him but like a
real confidence it's not like I'm doing
this because people want me to be the
guy that has it all together he like
actually believes these things about
himself and I remember reading something
once where you said after games he goes
and watches film with your coach and
you're like you never see guys ever do
that on the plane yeah yeah what is it
about Ben that just like makes him so
focused like that I think it's like he
lives by what he says and like he always
says like some people play the game
because they love it I play the game
because I want to be one of the greatest
and like obviously that's a very lofty
goal like you know like that's really
shooting for the stars but like why
wouldn't he he's like see 19 20 years
old like why wouldn't he go for that and
he's doing things that you know you've
never seen a rookie do uh he's been
amazing this year and like you said like
that confidence is real yeah like in
everything we do every everything like
we were filming something the other day
where he had to make a jumper and they
were like just don't shoot it right here
and he was like why wouldn't I shoot it
like shoot if you think you'll make it
he's like I'm shooting it yeah I think
I'll make them all yeah like that's
that's how he is and like I love Ben
because I love that energy and like when
you have a guy around you like that it's
like how do you not share that how you
not share that sent to me like this
guy's got all that confidence in himself
like how do like I got to too like yeah
this is like the Swagger that we play
with and so
um he's been awesome uh he's a he's like
a quiet guy when you first get to meet
him
um but he you know once he starts to
open up like man love having been around
um and you know he's just a great guy
that I could mess around with all the
time it's confidence a thing that you
ever had to work on for sure no question
yeah yeah and and I think like
externally probably not like uh like
sharing that I have confidence in myself
or like looking like I have confidence
in myself I don't think I've ever had to
work on that but inside like having to
think like yeah for sure like when I
first got to college
um you know I was like expected kind of
expected to like red shirt and like
mentally I was like I'm not red shirting
your chance and like I lived that
externally like I worked so hard and I
believed in everything I did but on the
inside there was like self-doubt for
sure
um and like you kind of got to work on
that as time goes on and then uh you
know I think going back to the trade
right like when I got traded I was like
I'm I was like yeah like externally I
was like I'm mad but um like I'm I know
I'm I know I'm good like I'm not worried
I'm gonna be great in Indiana but on the
inside a little bit I was like I don't
know like I might go there and struggle
like I I had to like think about that
for a second and like you don't want to
show that as an athlete because I
sometimes because I feel like if if I
were to come up and say that or
something like that like if somebody
could it's like smelling blood in the
water sometimes for other athletes right
yeah they see that and I want to say
something right or like get like you
know uh attack you more and now you're
thinking about it more uh but yeah I was
definitely there at one point and there
is times like we talked about earlier
with my shot or whatever when you're
struggling you think about it a little
bit uh but it's just kind of
understanding who you are and I was
talking to Rico Hines the other day out
with me and Zach and it's like family to
me and he was like you worked so hard to
to take the last shot to do certain
things like like why do you work what's
the point of working then like why why
do you work so hard if you you're not
going to use that to trust your ability
and I thought that was really like it
was like something small but I really
had to think about that like that's real
like I do work really hard and like so I
have to trust myself to take shots or uh
like I've earned that right you know by
my hard work so
um yeah I think that's a great
perspective on it yeah because it sounds
like you're saying confidence is really
about like trusting your own ability but
like trusting that you can do it yeah
yeah and so if you're dealing with that
internally what are like the tools that
you are like flexing to get better at
that internally
yeah how do you do that yeah yeah I
think um well you talked about a little
earlier about like kind of like goal
setting
um and like kind of people say like if
your girls have a timer like in like
love right like Words of Affirmation
right you know what I mean is that your
love language no that's not mine that's
not my love language uh but
um like I think kind of like internal
words of affirmation for myself right to
be like this is what I want to do this
these are my goals this is like how I
see myself as a player and like I need
to truly believe that inside for me to
achieve that and like coming into this
year I was like I feel like I could be a
2010 guy in the league and like some
people like yeah that's probably
realistic and some people were like
that's gonna be tough and like on the
inside uh I was just like no like I can
do that and I don't care what people
think like that's doable for me
um and I'm right there at that goal as
of right now and like so like on the
inside like I truly believe that and so
it's easy to like live that out like the
fact that I truly believe it no I love
that you're saying on this because I am
such a firm believer in the fact that
confidence is a tool like you should be
as confident as you are kind or as you
are a hard worker like all of the traits
that we discuss confidence I think is
kind of the foundation of all of those
things because if you don't fully
believe in those things about yourself
there's no way you can expect anyone
else to fully believe in those things
but it is something you also do have to
work on and sometimes working on
confidence means really working on that
thing that you need to be confident
about so I'm happy that like this
journey has led you to like more Supreme
confidence in yourself and that's bled
into all of the other things um that
you're doing as well yeah
um one thing I always ask folks I know
we talked about the draft left a bit
it's fascinating to me when players are
coming into the league and they are like
fulfilling this dream and they have all
these players they've been watching
their whole lives and now they know that
they're going to go against them you're
obviously over all of the like Fanning
that you are now because you've been in
the league for some time at this point
but which player took the longest for
you to get over the fact that you would
be playing against them
oh man that's crazy uh I don't know I
think there's a lot of guys like my
first preseason game was Dame and mellow
and I was like and CJ and I was like nah
this is crazy right now like yeah I
don't know what's going on I've told a
CP story where he thought I said
something on the bench but I was really
just like looking at him like yo it's CP
and somebody else said something he
thought it was me and he was mad at me
um is he over it now he's over it now
okay we're good now uh but I think
everybody thought it was going to be
LeBron for me because I grew up I had a
LeBron Fathead on my wall like you know
the big life-size dunk picture yeah
um and by the time I played him at the
end of the year I was kind of over that
like he said like the fan aspect of
things for me it was probably Kyrie I'm
gonna be real because like I grew up a
big brown fan so like the 2016.
Cavs Championship like I was fully
invested in that whole year and the
playoff run the finals run and so like
to me he's like Kyrie has no weaknesses
as a basketball player and I believe
that before I was in the NBA and I I
believe that even more as an NBA player
really and Kyrie is a guy who's like
like he's my position as well you know
what I mean so like I'm really he's like
guarding me like I'll guard him like
I'll get switched onto him from time to
time like we're the same position so it
like he's in front of me more and the
first time I ever played the first time
I played him he had 40. second time I
played him I had a really good game and
he like acknowledged me at the game we
had a like great conversation after the
game and that meant a lot to me because
then that was kind of like the like I
was like all right Kyrie said went up to
me James said what up to me and they
both told me like just keep going
um after that one I was kind of like all
right yeah like I'm cool I'm over the
fan things like I'm good though
yeah no that's so far because it's like
that is such a tangible way that you're
like no I I made it yeah I'm doing the
thing that I have worked to do my entire
life and I am amongst the people that I
have been watching my entire life yeah
and sports is just one of the the few
things where like you very visibly see
the dream come true I just think it's
it's really great like that's why I love
draft night that's probably my favorite
of all of it because that's the
beginning of this moment you know for
sure and yeah car is probably car's
probably the number one Fred Van Fleet
said something to me early in the early
in my rookie career too that like I've
never talked about before but that was
probably the first like confidence boost
or like yeah you're nice from another
NBA player that like you know like a
significant NBA player that I was like
oh like maybe I'm okay you know like
Fred we played the Raptors they smacked
us they beat us bad we had like 20 at
one point in the game and then I think
and then and then they started going
crazy maybe it's like 25 and after the
game Fred came up to me he was like yo
Young fella like where you are right now
like you gotta achieve for more like
right now you're a role player Off the
Bench now you want to get to a sixth man
how do you get from a six-man to a
starter how do you give him a starter to
a star how do you give him a star you
know All-Star Superstar like and like
for Fred to pull me aside and like it
was kind of like he I don't know if he
like saw that in me necessarily but was
kind of like nah like believe in what
you you know believe in believing
yourself and like that's his big thing
right bet on it yeah bet on yourself and
when Fred said that to me it was kind of
like that that meant a lot to me to be
honest and like I've never talked about
that before but uh yeah Fred's saying
that to me it meant a lot to me early in
my career and still like every time I
play Fred it's like I always remember
you know kind of those words you gave me
and that that means a lot to me I love
that so what do you think Fred Van Lee
saw in you in that moment yeah I I don't
know I I had a decent game that game and
I don't know I was left in the game at
the end of the game I felt like I was
probably still playing hard and uh I
don't know I think he just saw me as a
basketball player and guy who played
hard and uh just kind of saw you know
something in me that you know maybe I
didn't even see it myself to be honest
so like for him to like pull me aside to
say that that's just why I'm like man
like as a when I'm like an older NBA guy
like I hope I hope like I can have a
moment like Fred had that like impacted
me I hope I can have that on somebody
else yeah that you've like carried with
you and remember have you been able to
tell Fred what it meant to you no we've
never talked about it nowadays now when
I see him it's like a pickup run uh and
it's like kind of just playing I've
never I've never talked to him about it
before but you would want him to know
that this is you hold that moment no I
love that I'll make sure I'll send this
to Fred and he knows okay one more
question for you
if you weren't an NBA player what would
you be doing wow it's a heck of a
question
I went to school for business management
my freshman year my sophomore year I
went to school for basketball so yeah I
don't know maybe I think necessarily in
the business world but uh I don't know
that's a great question probably
something in the Fashion World to be
honest oh yeah probably something there
uh I saw even in the fits up in the
tunnel this year trying to get some pits
off uh my we got like a little short
slime we're doing here soon when it gets
warmer uh like well uh that stuff's just
interesting to me and I've always wanted
I've always enjoyed like putting my name
on things like as a kid like shoes or
whatever the case may be yeah like I was
that kid who went on Nike id all day
just to put you know his name on the
shoes or whatever never bought them
though yeah uh but yeah probably
something in the Fashion World don't
know exactly what uh but I would love to
do you know t-shirts or shorts or
whatever like that stuff interests me I
thought you'd say WWE oh I have a low
pain tolerance okay yeah you can't do it
I couldn't do it I could I could be a
talker on there and like they told me
they came into and we're in season so
like
they were a little like they were like
yo we didn't know you were gonna come so
we didn't like plan for you to do
anything uh so hopefully one day we can
but I'm not gonna ask for permission I'm
probably gonna ask for forgiveness yeah
they will not let me do that
every patient person here close your
ears
no what would your be Persona be like
what
what is the Tyrese
I like I don't know identity in WWE The
Arrogant like the bad guys are more I'm
more of a fan of them but you're like so
not bad guy I know but it's a persona
it's like you know what I mean yeah it's
you I mean not I mean they're not real
monsters they're gonna be your Alter Ego
you would step into that and be able to
be like yeah I talk a lot so I could you
know yeah hopefully I had like a big
dude next to me who does all the
fighting and I'm just kind of the talker
you know like that would be that'd
probably be me and then you just stick
him on everybody yeah get a nice fit off
every every week yeah that'd be me for
sure I love that well you truly you know
that I mean this you're one of my
absolutely favorite people in the league
thank you so much for doing this giving
us your time and I love watching you
with the Pacers and I hope that it
continues to just be up from here yeah
thank you I appreciate it absolutely
thanks Tyrese
[Music]